for you
okay
[Music]
Christian
s
[Music]
foreign
and everybody's so happy and greeting
each other
like it's everybody's happy to be around
each other is amazing welcome to the
table good to see you all
uh thank you for those of you who are
joining us online we're glad that you're
here to join us as well my name is Don
Jacobs and I will just personally want
to say that I am thrilled to be standing
in this room with you all this evening
not to get into all my progress but I
have just had all been in a foxhole in
the last several weeks and so I'm just
glad to be here and seeing your your
faces and spending time with you guys
and
been amazing it's amazing to see you
guys
um so a couple quick announcements
before we get started
um so obviously Christmas is right
around the corner we're gonna be doing a
Christmas Eve
um celebration at 4 30
um that evening so please make sure if
you want to participate or be here we're
gonna be doing candle lighting Christmas
carols
um the kids are welcome to be in here
because we're going to be a kid-friendly
situation so we would love for them to
participate as well nurseries being
provided for all the littles so please
make sure and to include anybody who has
kids friends families neighbors they
don't have a church home they are
looking for a space to be in this is a
perfect time to you're just
the door and for them just kind of show
up and everything like that for some
reason people just show up on Christmas
Eve celebrations it's kind of
interesting so it's a great time to get
visitors in the door
so please please encourage them to come
here
um then also we're not gonna be meeting
Christmas day but we are going to be
meeting Christmas
um excuse me not Christmas but New
Year's Day there we go New Year's Day so
we are going to be meeting that day so
there's one Sunday there to kind of keep
in mind
um but on New Year's Day I'm actually
kind of looking forward to this because
this is kind of what we do almost every
single year we get to hear from the
community and just kind of experiences
and things I'm kind of excited to see
who
Brett's kind of
going to have have in front of us some
kind of Interest
and I just I love hearing the stories
anyway but anyway so good to see you
guys I'm going to start us off with a
prayer and get started with worship
Lauren thank you so much for bringing us
all here tonight
thank you for just the space uh to be in
where we can just not just be together
but we can just focus on you in this
season and just what you mean to our
lives open our hearts and our minds to
what you have for us tonight in Christ
amen
amen thanks Dawn
um it's so good to see so many faces out
there
um that we haven't seen in a while we're
gonna get started with Go Tell It on the
Mountain if you guys want to stand with
us and our kids aren't in here tonight
like they usually are so if y'all could
sing like some children you know just
somebody like be messing around or like
poking their neighbor putting someone in
a headlock that would just help you know
fill that void that we normally have in
this first song
[Music]
foreign
Tell It on the mind the mountain that
Jesus Christ is born
the shepherd's feared and trembled when
low above the Earth
rang out the angel chorus that held the
savior's birthday
glow Tell It on the Mountain that Jesus
Christ is born
[Music]
down in the lowly manger The Humble
Christ was born
and God sent us salvation
thy blessed Christmas morning
over the hills and everywhere
that Jesus Christ
[Music]
[Laughter]
that Jesus Christ is born
me
[Music]
who
all right we're gonna move into the
prayers of the people and if you're
joining us online please leave a comment
there and we will try to share it aloud
with the room and you guys also feel
welcome to share what's whatever you're
carrying whoever or whatever you're
carrying tonight in this space
can you guys read this aloud with me
for the city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
so we lift these names and situations up
to you
Jewel and Sue
for those living on the streets
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light healing and hope peace and a
deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
lose my ability
to be afraid when I see the way you love
me
and all the fear that held my
feet to the floor
it don't hold me anymore
when I
see your face
Everything
Changes in the
radiance of your smile
you got this way
chasing away those
Shadows that hang around
Lord I fall down
again
I'm finding out just who I am
lose my ability
to be afraid when I hear you say my name
[Music]
it's all the voices at once
fill my head
they are gone when you speak
but when I
see your face
Everything Changes in the
radiance of your smile
you got this away
chasing away those
Shadows that hang around
Lord I fall down again
I'm finding out just who I am
would I fall down again
goodbye fear goodbye shame
goodbye hopelessness and pain
I have heard the father
called my name
goodbye running goodbye hiding goodbye
heaviness
the new has come the old is washed away
joy in heaven
and the love I've done for you
I've waited for all of this moments
my day hello Mercy hello peace you have
found me on my knees
and I believe I'll never be the same
[Music]
Everything Changes
Radiance will be your smile
[Music]
shadows and hang around
see your face
Everything Changes
[Music]
that hang around
foreign
[Music]
Lord I fall down again
I'm finding out just who I am
hello Joy hello truth hello love I've
longed for you
I've waited for this moment
all my days
[Music]
as we go into this next song I just
wanted to share with you guys
um
something that kept coming to my mind as
we were preparing for the set was just
what are we trading in
and these songs have a lot of lyrics
about letting go of one thing to receive
another
and as we come to this time together in
this space
I just encourage you guys to be thinking
what is it that I'm letting go of what
could I trade in so that I can pick up
all that God has for me so that I can
grab on to the things that the gospel
has to bring
and um
there's a lot of heaviness even here on
the stages we were sharing together we
had a moment in that room where
there's a lot going on there's a lot of
heaviness there's a lot of pain
suffering loss
and and and I want to share that one to
just name we're all in this together
there's no separation from up here to
down there
um
we're just people coming together and
trying to be real about where we're at
and also trying to give a little bit of
space
to see what God may have in return
and I believe even if you can't believe
it for yourself right now even if
there's things that you're holding on to
that are too hard to let go of too
painful
I want to believe for you that he has a
better way that he has good in store
and maybe that's the people around you
who want to give love and support maybe
that's people in your family or maybe
it's totally outside of that
um but I just encourage you to open
yourself up as much as you can to maybe
even just the idea that there's
something more there's something better
than the things that are Weighing on me
right now
and um trust him in that
trust the spirit of love
the spirit of Truth and forgiveness the
spirit of reconciliation and Hope
because if there's anything that this
season reminds us of it's that when we
are waiting in suffering that God has
come to give us something good that God
is bringing hope and light to a dark and
weary world
so let's grab on to that as we go into
this next song together
[Music]
overwhelmed by the way of your sin
Jesus is Calling
have you come to the end of yourself
do your thirst for a Dream from the well
Jesus is Calling
oh come to
the altar
the father's arms
[Music]
forgiveness
was bought with
the precious blood of Jesus Christ
leave behind your regrets in this
to come today there's no reason to wait
Jesus is Calling
bring your sorrow and trade them for joy
From the Ashes
Jesus is called me
Oh Come True
[Applause]
[Music]
forgiveness
was brought with
the precious blood of Jesus Christ
[Music]
it isn't he
wonderful
soon Hallelujah
Christ is risen
[Music]
bow down before
for he is
[Music]
[Applause]
a reason
[Music]
Hallelujah
Christ is
bow down before he
is
[Music]
[Applause]
friends
oh come to
the altar
the father's arms
[Music]
of Jesus Christ
[Applause]
[Music]
Jesus Christ
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's God tonight
we want to leave behind the things that
are not from you
[Music]
our sadness
our struggle
our control
our insecurities
[Music]
our failures
tonight with your truth with your peace
with your hope reign in our hearts
[Music]
Even in our darkest places would we find
your light breaking in
would we hold on to your hope
that you make beautiful things out of
our mess
that you turn our ashes into something
beautiful
[Music]
that you can make a way
Even in our own hearts and mind God
would you make a way
where we are hardened
[Music]
where we have built walls
where we have made mistakes
God would you come and have your way
would you renew and redeem us
would we find you forgiving
and kind
[Music]
would we find you present
foreign
fill us with joy
fill us with peace and love
[Music]
we make room for you God
it's in your name that we pray all these
things
amen
foreign
thanks guys you can turn to the people
around you and welcome them make them
feel at home and then Brett will get us
started on the message
all right
good evening
Grace and peace
welcome to the table I'm so so glad to
be just with you all and um as always
that welcome includes those joining us
online love you lots and anyone here who
is new thank you for being Among Us so
it is it's the season of Advent here at
the table and uh there's kind of four
themes of Advent it's at the time of
Love Of Joy of
um Peace and hope and those four themes
of course really just deeply connect
with who Christ was and is and so and I
hope from
just this time together whether it's a
prayer we pray or a song We Sing or
something from the message that uh as
many was talking about what you kind of
trade you know I I hope one thing you
receive is like one of those you know
more love more joy more peace more hope
because frankly our world could use a
whole lot more of that and uh and we
could too in our own lives so
um yeah at any rate so our our Series
right now is
um because it's Advent it's Advent at
the table
as I said last week Uber creative we
spent hours trying to think that up
um not really but
um so this the season of Advent for
those who maybe it's a little bit
unfamiliar
um so it's not exactly synonymous with
Christmas instead it's the season
um leading up to Christmas so it really
becomes a time to not only reflect on
love and joy and peace and hope um but
also to reflect on Christ's um arrival
as his coming among us and that ends up
being um kind of a season where we
reflect on how Christ has arrived like
in the first Christmas uh the way Christ
continues to show up in our lives in in
our midst through worship through
communion just through the Holy Spirit
as we're out in the world and God just
like meets us sometimes you know like
you've had those maybe it's a
conversation with someone and suddenly
it's like I don't know God's showing up
in that space I mean of course at some
level you know Christ is always present
but you know what I mean like you have
those moments
um that are really special so Advent
kind of covers that and the way Christ
will arrive um what's commonly known as
the second um coming to arrival of
Christ at the end um really of all
things when God is all in all so kind of
all those that's all like Advent it's
really about
um God's arrival so um with that in mind
the the title of of my message tonight
is rethinking sin because our scheduled
reading with with Advent comes these
kind of scheduled readings that you know
tend to kind of align with like the
Christmas story or something prophetic
about Christ's arrival or something and
so our scheduled reading this week is um
Matthew chapter
um one uh verses 18 through 21 and it
says this this is how the birth of Jesus
the Messiah came about
his mother Mary was pledged to be
married to Joseph
but before they came together she was
found to be pregnant through the holy
spirit because Joseph her husband was
faithful to the law and yet did not want
to expose her to Public Disgrace he had
in mind to divorce her quietly but after
he had considered this an angel of the
Lord appeared to him in a dream and said
Joseph son of David
do not be afraid to take Mary home as
your wife because what is conceived in
her is from the Holy Spirit
she will give birth to a son and you are
to give him the name Jesus because and
here's our key line for tonight he will
save his people from their sins
that's all I want to focus on he will
save his people from their sins it was
Theologian Rowan Williams uh who he was
really in this definition I'm going to
give you
um he's talking about specifically kind
of the Way Saint Paul thought of Sin
from the New Testament but I think this
is really bloody or broadly applicable
um throughout the Bible uh so Ron
Williams he says this when Saint Paul
talks about Sin it's obvious that he
thinks first of a climate of thinking
and behavior in which we have become
incapable of relating to God or each
other
except in fear rivalry and suspicion
a climate in which we take it for
granted that what's good for the other
is likely to be bad for us
that's I I think um
I think this is a fantastic way to start
to re-imagine or re-understand in a
deeper way what sin like actually is I
love this metaphor he gives of climate a
whole um a whole climate of thinking and
behavior you know when I think of
climate of course I'm thinking of like a
uh kind of a consistent weather pattern
that just settles upon a region and uh
and it basically just you know it's kind
of their main of course they can kind of
shift with the seasons a little bit but
it's basically what people just come to
expect and treat honestly as normal you
know that's just kind of what you get
with climate and uh it wasn't until I
actually left Texas for a little while
um some of it was I had some time at a
school
um in South Carolina but then later I
went to um I attended a seminary it was
mostly online if I have to travel up to
Portland for like sometimes you know 10
days at a time or whatever and having so
much time away from Texas in such a
different climate I realized
um well first I'll describe Portland I
mean most of you know it's like right
Pacific Northwest so it's just drizzly
but here's the thing like no
thunderstorms
I mean or very rarely like it's not like
like Texas basically you know Texas is
just like it's like so violent here I
mean we had it this week some of you are
like taking cover you know it's like
welcome to Texas
um but that's not it's not that's not
the climate you know it's just kind of
gentle drizzly rain of course the
downside is it sort of does that all the
time you know she's kind of like well
it's just gonna rain I don't know what's
the what's the weather rain but gentle
gentle right
uh and then of course you get to Texas
and it's like oh my God who knows you
know we just get used to like 60 mile
per hour winds again I didn't realize
Texas was windy until I left
and I realized oh so I've lived in a
very windy place my whole life didn't
realize that why because you just you
know you just get used to your climate
right in Portland you wake up you have
your raincoat and Texas you wake up if
it's summer you're like slather on the
sunscreen or you know jump in the
bathtub with your family mattress on top
of you anyone do the mattress on top
like that's the if you're a really
hardcore really want to be safe some of
you Enneagram Sixes who were like all
about the safety like we've got to get
this mattress on top of us you know um
but it's just normal right if you're in
Texas your whole life you're like of
course we jump in the bathtub with a
mattress on top of us it's it's just the
weather you know
um so you can see kind of what I'm
driving out here right climb a whole
climate is just a thing you come to
accept as normal even though of course
it like shifts and changes depending on
you know kind of where you are and I
think in a similar way
um Williams he's naming this is how like
sin kind of functions in a given
um people or like a culture it just um
it just kind of settles upon you and in
this way I think it's helpful because we
often have I think honestly rather like
kind of somewhat extreme and silly kind
of characterizations of sin at times
like we kind of think in these extremes
you know like for some people
um sin is would be something like
um you know worshiping or like praising
Satan and murdering people you know it's
like well I don't murder anyone you know
so it's sort of like that's like one
extreme kind of that and then or on the
other you have you know sin is just
doing fun things that God hates for some
reason no one really knows why but just
don't have any fun you'll be safe you
know so it's like these are this is
often how we think of you know sin
that's that's the sin so just it is it's
kind of silly because it's as though
like if we could just get people to
either stop murdering or stop enjoying
their beer or dancing you know or
something like then the world's problems
will be solved right and it's like okay
this is
we are off base you know we're not we're
I don't think we're we're quite um
tracking and so this is what I I think
sin is really much more in line with
what Williams is kind of describing here
where it's much more it's about um
relationship
it's much more about how am I relating
to myself
how am I relating
um to other people
and um I also love that that Williams he
really has our culture like he's writing
in from the UK
um but I think it's broadly applicable
like it's it's typical here too with you
know the US like Western culture his
word his keywords in that quote were
fear rivalry and suspicion
I just man when I think of kind of our
times you know it's just a time of fear
oh fear I mean kind of Perpetual you
know just fear and then rivalry there's
sort of like we're extremely tribal you
know so it's not always just individuals
but it's like this group against that
group against that group and we're just
all like you know so it's just a time a
season of fear rivalry suspicion
but remember like climate it's just been
this way though for so long
we accept it as what
normal it's like oh yeah
it's just how the world is there's and
because of that we can't um
we can't really see our way out
um and in ways I do think you know like
systems can kind of contribute to this
by systems I mean um you know like
societal structures
um institutions like like political
systems or religious systems or social
systems or education or
um economic systems like for example I
think like on one upside to say
um like capitalism as like an economic
system it has it's true like produce
tremendous abundance for the world you
know like on the one hand like we it's
we have fewer people in poverty than
like at any point in human history ever
so that's like wow well that's cool but
on the other hand it has absolutely kind
of contributed to our kind of thin
problem in the sense Rowan Williams is
talking about right in the sense that we
like here we're all like yeah go team
you know team Jesus then we like walk
out the doors
and suddenly just the nature of the
system itself is we're all competing
with one another
and it's just now again can you see how
it's just like well
it's just how it is
but you know theologians um not just
Christian ones but have pointed out that
there's that kind of contributes to some
problems
because suddenly well it's back to the
fear rivalry suspicion thing you know
it's like we're there's we feel as
though there's scarce resources and so
we're like fighting tooth and nail you
know I mean there's just that that
anxiety that that competitiveness and
it's not just though as like producers
even as consumers like is there any more
insane picture
of Western culture than those security
video camera shots that come out of
people trampling one another to get to
Black Friday sales at six have you seen
some of these when they like circulate
and make the news like
whoa like what like what
I guess um what am I driving at I I
guess
um
well I'll let me quote this this is this
is
um actually I know this might be a
little strange for some of you but I
want to quote the Buddha
um I'm not a Buddhist per se but I do
appreciate some of his his thoughts and
this I think is a powerful
um image he he said this I'll tell you
about the Dreadful fear that caused me
to shake all over
seeing creatures flopping around like
fish in water too shallow so hostile to
one another
seeing this I became afraid this world
it completely lacks Essence it it
trembles in all directions I long to
find myself a place unscathed but I
could not see it seeing people Locked In
conflict I became completely distraught
I mean is that not that's a powerful
image that uh that's always stuck with
me I've never forgotten this quote the
first time I read it because of that
image of the fish flopping around in
water too shallow
like what's that a picture of it's it's
a picture of fear I'm not getting enough
and I've got to fight with you for
enough
it's the it's I mean it's Rowan Williams
quote it's the fear it's the Rivalry
it's the suspicion
you know in essence what I'm naming is
um
we need to be saved y'all
we need you need to be saved I need to
be saved like this is and I wondered I
was really curious how
how that opening line would hit you he
will save his people from their sins
just I'm so curious like I don't know
for some of you maybe your eyes kind of
glazed over a little bit I don't know
maybe you've heard all the sin talks or
something you know maybe for others it
was just like a little peculiar I don't
know was it hokey it kind of strike you
as like a little religious and outdated
and you know he will save his people
from their sins I just want a name oh
it's it's not you know like it's not
outdated like no no
oh we we need to be saved so I guess the
question is how
how will we be saved uh this brings us
of course back to Christmas because we
could talk about like cross and
Resurrection that's a different season
in the church calendar so I won't
emphasize that
um instead I what what Christians
believe is that in a very big broad
sense
um there was something healing
there's something you might say um
salvific like like saving about just the
very Act of God becoming human
this comes back to something we talked
about
um a few weeks ago about how we think of
bodies and how the New Testament thinks
about he's like We tend to think of
ourselves as very separate
from one another you know separate
selves
um but the New Testament thinks of us as
very connected
and so when God becomes human
he unleashes like a certain healing
upon Humanity
and and that's something that's
something beautiful and wonderful and
Powerful in our life now having said
that I do think at times when we talk
about how you know Jesus thinks he will
save his people from their sins and even
the Incarnation you know begins that
process of healing us and saving us I I
think um
well it's true it can feel a little bit
like removed
does that make sense like removed from
like my life your life like today
in other words we can kind of believe in
an abstract sense like okay God is is
saving me you know from my sins but but
we kind of might be pushed to ask like
yeah
but
like how does that play out like today
you know I mean like here I am
caught up in my fear caught up in my
anxiety caught up in my rivalry and my
suspicion and my tribe and we're all
fighting and hostile and one other like
how okay but like how does this play out
in my life today how will we be saved
today
uh there's a beautiful film it's a
little far
so it's not for everyone
um it's by Terence Malek who is a
football director so that tells you a
lot if you've seen any of his films um
but it's the the Tree of Life uh have
any of you seen tree of life it's a one
two three okay we got some of my family
members of course I'm like you've got to
see tree of life and they're like okay
again
um it's wonderful there's a there's a
quote uh where one of the characters
says this the nuns taught us
there are two ways through life
the way of nature
in the way of Grace
you have to choose
which one you'll follow
Grace doesn't try to please itself
accepts being slighted
forgotten disliked accepts insults and
injuries
but nature only wants to please itself
get others to please it too likes to
Lord it over them to have its own way it
finds reasons to be unhappy when all the
world is shining around it and love is
smiling through all things
that beautiful
when I think of
the teachings of Christ I think of
someone
desperately trying to show us how to be
saved
today
and and what that looks like
is him showing us the way of Grace
which is so different than the way of
nature fear rivalry suspicion hostility
conflict flopping around like fish in
water too shallow can you hear the way
of nature as opposed to the way of Grace
so yes what's the way of Grace how does
that look at this point in my um draft
number one of this sermon which draft
number one is never very good I mean
it's debatable whether it ever gets too
good but I always you know I try
um and it's better draft Two Is Better
Than One and draft one I had long
excerpts of Jesus teachings and I
realized oh gosh okay this is too much
too many quotes So I've got I'm gonna
condense and summarize for you this is
from Luke chapter six every every line
of this is from Luke chapter six or Luke
12 and here are like words that I
thought just captured like the essence
of Christ teaching and point towards the
way of Grace and it really summarized
the heart posture
of someone following the way of Grace
it's this untroubled
that's from Luke 12 22. warm-hearted
non-judgmental
non-anxious
forgiving
greedless generous
like this is the way of Grace this is
what it looks like to be saved today in
other words each of us wakes up each
morning
and we say some kind of Prayer
and I hope it's something like oh God
today
may I not follow
the way of nature
the way that everyone else is going
Jesus help me follow the way of Grace
and
you know a list like this maybe it
strikes you as a little bit uh
idealistic like well I'd love to be that
you know untroubled warm-hearted
non-judgmental non-anxious forgiving and
greedless and generous and like oh yes
but I mean does anyone I mean maybe
you're even thinking like I know
Christians you know does anyone really
live in this well you know um I hear you
I hear you and and here's what I would
say
to follow Christ long enough and
Faithfully enough over time
your life can increasingly come to
reflect this not perfectly not like all
the time I'm just Flawless you know um I
think Christian Saints down to centuries
kind of give us models and hope for like
what a life
um like that can can look like
and you know occasionally I meet folks
like this
and uh it's always it's always a joy I I
remember
um I had an experience this was man
probably six seven years ago I was
actually working at a different church
at this time and uh we had this
Gathering of pastors
which is um what we were trying to plan
a like Community event all the churches
were gonna get together I think it was
actually this time of year we're going
to do like a Christmas
service something for the community you
know and uh I'll tell you all it's
always a little weird to get like all
the pastors together
um partly because we're caught up in sin
too and
um
the whole cultural climate of fear and
rivalry
in competition all that is like alive
and well even among churches I know
we're supposed to be better
but um we're just kind of not you know
it's really hard and maybe it's also
that pastors are so used to being in
charge so you get a bunch of pastors
together to plan a thing and they're I
don't know there's just a Vibe you know
so needless to say as as we were all
there and I I this is me too I was in
the midst of it too like there was kind
of this weird even a pecking order kind
of developing where you had like you
know the like successful pastors you
know which of course meant
big churches you know I mean and then
there was kind of like and it was like
the hierarchy kind of like and there's
kind of a Vibe of like who was really
gonna have to say and you know what I
mean like there's just this whole thing
and then of course people are starting
to like talk over one another and
they're and they're kind of trying to
haggle for like who's gonna get what
part of the community service you know
you didn't want to be relegated to some
small elements you know so it was just
anyway it was just a bit of a mess but
the whole time we're all here kind of
flopping around like fish
um off to the side I noticed this one
um man this one pastor I didn't know his
name I knew he passed with like a super
small community
um and I kept looking over him because
he was he was just he was just sitting
there and he was just looking at us and
he had this like little half smile like
he was just
like he was just that he was just
watching us and I kept
stealing glances over him honestly he
looked so at peace and as opposed to all
of us and I'm looking over him and he's
just kind of watching and he never said
a word like never asked to like oh what
about what can I do you know he just
just kind of sat there his church didn't
get a part in the service because I
don't know he never spoke up you know uh
he did he seemed um
I don't know
you're such a different
uh for lack of me is the clunky term but
vibe
and
uh
afterwards we finish and he comes over
to me maybe he saw me awkwardly
looking I don't know but he comes over
to me and he's um he says hi Brett
Church
how are you doing he starts asking me
like all these questions he was so
personable
so at peace
so non-rivalists
with me
I mean it was he was a beautiful soul
that's like that's the only one know how
to put it like he was a beautiful soul
in a way that honestly
um
no one else there was at least that day
myself included
um what's
what's going on how how could he sit
there so um untroubled and warm-hearted
and
non-judgmental and you know like how
could he do that
well I don't think it's like some exact
you know formula but I suspect it has
something to do some combination
of Prayer
and worship
community
confession
solitude
silence
what's happened
Jesus has begun to save him from his
sins
today
and Church like this is our call
this is our call
when I um
when I think about myself I think of how
like you and I
um we need to be saved
not only in some big Cosmic ontological
sense
but in a very nitty-gritty down-to-earth
ways saved from our greed
save from my anger save from my anxiety
save for my resentment save from my fear
and this is why the scriptures great
promise is that Christ will save his
people from their sins
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight
as we take in the body of Christ and the
bread the blood of Christ and the wine
as we remember again the Christ too
came to Earth to save us to to unleash
that healing power my prayer is that
like a little bit of that fear and
rivalry and suspicion and hostility and
a little bit of that stuff that's gotten
into us maybe maybe more than a little
um that like some some piece of that
would be broken off tonight as we take
in Christ
so um we're going to take communion a
little bit differently because we're
going to have three folks serving which
means we'll still form one line but if
you're sitting on this side you'll be
able to kind of go this way and receive
a cup that way and if you're here you
can move that way and
um yes an upgrade in our process so
thank you Raymond Lester for organizing
this so we we practice what's called an
open table here meaning if you're here
tonight and you want to participate
you are free to do so
um there's something in you that wants
to connect with Christ
you just you just come forward and and
connect
um
invites you to the table this is a
Celtic Christian invitation this is the
table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith in you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
in you who have failed
come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here come to
the table
foreign
[Music]
you guys are welcome to sing along if
you know this song
um but also feel free to just sit back
and take in the words Joe's gonna lead
it
I want to just help us kind of prepare
our hearts for this season that we're in
of Advent
[Music]
foreign
and can you hear the
angels singing
[Music]
to the light of the world
glory
[Music]
to the light of the world
is he
here
the child breaks with the tears of a
mother a baby's cry is the sound of love
come down
come down imagine
[Music]
oh he is the song for the suffering
his Messiah the Prince of Peace
[Music]
no
worry to the light of the world
glory
to the light of the world
[Music]
up to the light of the world
for all who hang there for all who pays
[Music]
glory to the light of the world
to the light of the world
[Music]
even you
the world waits for a miracle
the heart longs for a little bit of Hope
Oh Come
Oh Come amen
[Music]
oh goodness
um thank you guys and thank you worship
team you guys are amazing as always
um just a quick reminder like I
mentioned to you guys earlier before
um
Christmas Eve service it's coming at 4
30. it's an easy for some reason it's
just an easy thing for people to just
agree to come to a church service on
Christmas I don't know what that is but
take advantage of it
um so if you've got somebody in mind
somebody a neighbor a friend a family
member
doesn't matter who it is we'd love for
them to join us
and with that being said I'd like to
send you guys out with this blessing
you're welcome to Stan welcome to sit
whatever you feel comfortable doing
so you are a child of God
you are a child of God
and this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day
so you just go into your week ahead with
this yet determined highs and lows and
everything in between go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved you are worthy and you were
accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love with
everyone you come in contact with
thank you and have a great great rest of
the week
[Music]
foreign
amen
amen you
[Music]
never waits for a miracle
the heart longs for a little bit of Hope
will come
Oh Come amen
[Music]